I wasn't another one before this one
Bobby Ross is deeply traumatized exactly
two years on from grenfell and he's back
in the same hotel he was sent to
immediately after the fire Bobby's dad
Steve power died in the blaze bobby
lived with him on the 15th floor of the
tower in the last two years he's moved
between nine different hotels and is
still not in a permanent home he says
the one he was given is a fire hazard
and has flooded three times kensington
council told us they fixed the problem
and the flat is ready I've already said
I don't want to live in that property
but I feel like I'm being forced to live
in that property they've said that fixed
there but they said that three times and
then obviously as you can see in the
video that a flood with war coming
through the lights I've just been in
standstill I've just been in one spot
every time I've tried to take two steps
forward I'm taking turn back
Bobby is one of seventeen grenfell
families who aren't living in a
permanent home while he and many others
are still fighting to get through each
day others are taking on the government
demanding change kareem mursili lost his
uncle in the fire everything has changed
yet nothing has changed for us at least
so many so many things have been sort of
brought to light in terms of what we see
now and what we've learned about
policies and you know Building
Regulations etc so I guess that's
something that's changes our new non
knowledge but what has actually happened
to make sure this never happens again
not a lot two years on from grenfell and
there's still so much frustration at the
lack of action there's been no arrests
no charges but 13 interviews under
caution and police chiefs admit it could
be a long wait until any charges are
brought my assessment of the public
inquiry is that it's unlikely to report
in its final terms until mid 2021 and if
that were the case then it's unlikely
any reports of the CPS to consider
charges would be any sooner than that
72 people died in the Grenfell fire two
years might have passed but time hasn't
dampened to strength or spirit of this
community as they come together once
more to remember their loved ones and
while justice if it comes is a long way
off
the people of Grenfell are clear they
will not give up fighting
Charlotte Lomas Sky News